all right it's a time I think there's
still people coming in just come on come
on in there's still room for everyone
but thank you all for coming
my name is Mark seaman and if you want
to know more about me there's
information they unblocked uploaded DK
and you can follow me on Twitter if
you're interested in figuring out what I
have to say so what I'm going to do
today is that I'm going to try to answer
a couple of frequently asked questions
and I'm gonna ask answer two different
frequently asked questions and it turns
out at first glance if you see both of
those questions you know side by side
it's not entirely clear you know why
they're related but it turns out that
they are right but what am I going to do
here I'm gonna give the talk in three
parts so in the first act of this
three-part talk I'm gonna talk about the
first frequently asked question and sort
of try to explain why it makes sense to
ask that question but then I'm not gonna
answer the question because we need some
more we need to learn some more stuff
before we can actually you know sensibly
ask that answer that question so in part
2 I'm gonna put aside the first question
for a while and then look at a different
question and then we go all the way
through and try to figure out how to
address that question and then then in
part three we've learned enough so that
we can come back to the first question
from part one and answer that in a
satisfactory manner so that's the that's
the plan
so three three acts of the talk if you
will so the first frequently asked
question that I'll try to address here
is how do I combine dependency injection
with a sink and a weight and that seems
easy enough but then with a little extra
qualification here without leaky
abstractions and in order to I explain
you know why this even is interesting to
talk about will will need to look at
some code examples in order to figure
out okay what do I even mean by this so
whenever I want to show you code
examples one of my favorite scenarios is
that you have to imagine that you want
to develop an online restaurant
reservation system
this is sort of my favorite scenario I
know all of these you know services
already exist out there but we could
just pretend that the world needs
another one of those so it's one of
those things where you know you want to
make a reservation at a restaurant so
you fill in a form on the website or
whatever and you know once you filled in
all the all the details you press the
submit button and the UI creates a
little JSON document and that JSON
document gets you know HTTP posted
against the web server somewhere and the
code that we're gonna look at is the
server-side code that handles that
incoming requests for a reservation so
we'll start at the domain model and at
the domain model the central decision is
embodied in a method that looks like
this so it's called try accept and it
takes a reservation as input so the
reservation is just that JSON document
or the data from that JSON document you
know the the dates the quantity the name
the email address and the return value
is an honorable int so what does that
mean well if it's an int that's a
reservation ID and if you have a
reservation ID that means you have a
reservation you can use that reservation
ID to cancel your reservation or make
changes to it or whatever so that means
you have a reservation if you don't have
an ID if that's null it means you don't
have a reservation so that's pretty
obvious I suppose so there are reasons
why sometimes we can't accept a request
for a reservation and we'll look at that
in a moment now if we're using
dependency injection we could you know
inject various different dependencies on
the class that has a method like this so
for example we could inject a repository
and just make it available as a as a
read-only property like this so on you
notice that I'm showing you members of
classes and I'll show you some
implementation code in a moment for the
try/except method but I'm not showing
you the surrounding class and that's
basically just because I don't have
space for that also I'm not showing you
the constructor that receives that
repository and saves send property for
later use its 2019 and I somehow naively
expect that people understand how
constructor injection looks
you know now in 2019 so I'm not showing
you that but we if we have a repository
like this we can query it so we can say
let me know give me all the reservations
for that reservation date and that's
just some some reservations and we can
do a sum over all the quantities and
that gives me a number of reserved seats
so that those are all the seats that are
already reserved for that particular
date and if we also know that capacity
of the restaurant we can make a business
decision so if we if the remaining
capacity is too little we have to return
null so this is the scenario where we
have to say well sorry we really like to
accept your reservation but we can't
because we're sold out or we at least
we've sold out of the tables of the size
that you need but if we get past this
though we can you know core repository
create and that will you know create the
reservation in the database and
repository create also returns an
integer and we're just gonna return that
int so right now there's no asynchrony
anywhere to be seen and all I'm just
gonna go through you know the standard
scenario first and then we'll look at
you know what what would what would it
look like to add asynchrony to this so
so this is our you know basic domain
model and if we want to you know in
embody that in some sort of type we
could create an interface called Maitre
D' that's sort of a half that defines
this method now Maitre D' is basically
just restaurant jargon for the head
waiter and it's a it's a role in typical
restaurants that sort of makes decision
on you know making sure that everyone is
at the right table and stuff like that
so it's just you know domain driven
design if you will once we have that we
also need to write the code that
actually receives the HTTP request and
creates a response so that's typically
something you put in a controller and in
this case we have a method called post
that gets called whenever we have an
HTTP POST against this sort of resource
and we receive that reservation as input
and then we return something called an
action we solve this output and if you
don't know what that is it's not really
important it's just an interface that
models an HTTP response and you'll see
you know how we return
things like that in a moment now if
we're doing dependency injection we
typically do it all the way so we could
inject that I'm HIV interface that I
just showed you and if I have an
independancy on that I can just calm HUD
to try except and that returns a
knowable int and then I can do a little
check on whether or not that's no and if
it's no I'll call the helper method so
internal server error is a little helper
method probably on the base class and it
returns one of those action results so
in this case and that just means that
the action result represents a 500
internal server error HTTP response on
the other hand if the try accept method
succeeded I return 200 okay so that's
another one of those action results and
notice that in the response body I pull
out the integer from that knowledge int
so ID dot value is now safe to ACTU
access so in the response body on that
200 okay responds is the integer that
you know reservation ID and that's the
protocol that's the contract that we
have with all the callers of our API
that we need to make sure that that
reservation ID remains in the body if if
the response is a 200 ok response now
this new async stuff going on at all but
if we look at the repository here we
would say well ok really if we want to
implement this this is something that
talks to a database you know typically
this is a just a relational database and
then you know you'd say well it'd be
nice if we could make that access
asynchronous because that might actually
improve our performance in various ways
at least it's worth a try so how do we
make stuff like this asynchronous well
the way that's done are you supposed to
do this in c-sharp is that you have to
change the return types so right now
they're just normal objects and you have
to make them tasks instead all right so
it's not a big big change code wise but
we've now just allowed an implementation
details to leak through into the
definition of what the abstraction looks
like you know abstraction should be
defined by
but the caller of the methods need and
that's that try except you know domain
model and it didn't need those things to
be asynchronous that's what's known as
the dependency inversion principle but
now we've allowed some implementation
detail to leak through into the
definition of our interface and then
you'd say well okay is it a big deal
everyone sort of knows that a repository
is really just a database so you say
well okay so it's always gonna be some
sort of our process resource at least so
isn't that okay and you can decide to
say well okay let's let's see where this
gets us because maybe that's okay I can
sort of you know get with that argument
that's fine so how do we how do we then
resolve you know are there any problems
here and it turns out that we need to
make some changes to try accept but
they're quite you know a few we just
have to add async in a wait and also we
need to change the return type of the
try accept method to a task but apart
from that this is all the changes that
we need to implement it that's not too
bad but you know I change the type of
try except that that means it's no
longer gonna compile on this I also
change the type of the try accept method
that the interface defines because
otherwise I'm no longer implementing
that interface so this is where I think
I'm beginning to get a little annoyed
with this because I can sort of accept
that well yeah okay a repository is
really not a process resource so it
should be asynchronous but this thing
here this is my domain model and I see
absolutely no compelling reason why my
domain model has to be asynchronous but
now it it does because of an
implementation detail so now that's you
know this bothers me but let's just move
on and see if there's more work to do
and there is a little bit more but it's
it's be almost done you know since we
Maitre D' to try except is now
asynchronous i also need to add a weight
and async and return a task instead here
but again very you know a few changes
they're easy to implement those changes
so it's not a big deal and at this point
we are done
I'm annoyed about the leaky abstraction
but apart from that it's not that it's
you know it's not that it's hard work to
make this change this is fairly easy to
do but as other people have pointed out
before me once you go async you have to
go acing all the way and you know this
is not a talk that tries to drive home
that point it's basically just to say
well this we know already there's no
other way and I'm always like you know
whenever people say something like that
there's no other way I'm my reaction is
tip of you oh really because you know I
just need to come up with one counter
example to say well yeah there is
another way and that means that you were
wrong there is another way and there is
now to be clear I'm gonna show you what
that other way is and I'm not I'm not
here to sell you on that other way I'm
not trying to I'm not trying to convince
you that the way that I'm gonna show you
now is better I believe that sometimes
it's better and I believe sometimes you
know what I've just shown you is a
pragmatic solution that's probably going
to be better for you but I believe in
you've given you alternatives so if you
don't know about the other way you
wouldn't know that it exists and that
means you don't have a choice now if
when you know when when the talk is over
you know that there's another way and
now you have a choice and then you can
make a decision so it's just to raise of
an awareness I'm not trying to sell you
on doing one thing or another but this
is where part one ends because in order
to figure out what the other way looks
like we need to learn some other stuff
first so I'm going to put aside the
dependency injection and the async/await
stuff a little bit and instead talk
about a completely unrelated question it
would look like but it turns out that
they're actually quite related so the
other question is how do I get the value
out of my monad and first of all I'm not
expecting you to know what a monad is
I'll go through that so once we're done
here you also know what a monad is so
this is really gonna be a lot of stuff
to learn here and it's super fun and
super easy not to be worried about at
all now the short answer to this
question is Moo
okay yeah so assuming everyone
understands Japanese right now but
there's this there's this interpretation
of this character and the the word mu in
Zen Buddhist philosophy and if you want
a Western perspective on that you
couldn't always consider reading the sin
and the art of motorcycle maintenance
because it's a good book or you could
read a good lesha Bach that's maybe a
little bit more programming oriented but
both of those books talk about this way
of sometimes asking or responding to a
question when people are asking a
question you say Moo and basically it
means on ask the question so the idea
here is that this is a response that
basically tells you the question doesn't
make any sense we should now talk about
you know why you would ask that question
and then you know once you've understood
that the question doesn't make any sense
you will become enlightened there's
always a lot of enlightenment in in Zen
Buddhism I suppose it's very closely
related to another thing there's more
maybe a little bit more down-to-earth
DXY problem now the x-y problem is
something that often happens when you
when you're trying to learn something
new something that you don't know how to
do yet and you're trying to learn it and
it's such a common thing that there's
actually a stack overflow flat a fact
that talks about the XY problem but
basically it's this thing where you're
trying to learn something new so a new
library a new language a new way of
doing things and you well you're
struggling with things because it's hard
to learn new stuff and that's completely
natural so if we could try to illustrate
that by saying you have a goal you're
trying to accomplish the goal why and
you have either implicitly or explicitly
formulated yourself a plan to how to
achieve the goal and you say well I'll
go through a series of steps and that
will enable me to reach the goal and one
of those steps will call X and then when
you try to execute on your plan it turns
out that you're stuck on X you can't
figure out how to do X and then you go
and ask on stackoverflow and the
friendly people on sock Stack Overflow
will you know immediately tell you oh
yeah that was me really making sense
that you're really trying to do so if
you engage into such you know in a
conversation like that you know someone
who really knows what it is that you're
trying to learn will understand that it
doesn't make sense to try to do X that's
a nonsensical question but once you
figure out you know by conversing with
an expert that you're really trying to
do Y that's your goal the expert will
say oh if that's what you're trying to
do you should do Z and Zed will enable
you to do X to the Y sorry so it's a
completely different way of thinking
about things and that happens a lot and
this happens often when monads are
involved as well so we often see lots of
very specific questions about specific
monads but I've sort of just try to
generalize the question to this so how
do we get the value out of my monad well
you don't let this make any sense that
question is nonsensical and but I think
it's worthwhile to just look at you know
why would you ask that question but
first we'll have to figure out what's a
monad because I'm not not assuming that
you know is and it's one of those things
where there's a lot of there's a lot of
Bath's around a word and a lot of people
find it intimidating but it's really not
you so if you forget about all the image
intimidation for a moment interesting
this is just a friendly practical thing
it is then just I'll teach you and it'll
take 15 minutes and then you'll know
what a monad is so just you know just go
to this with an open mind and it'll be
fine
now what's a monad okay a little bit
more jargon here it's a function you can
flatten and then you go okay that's not
very helpful what's a functor so we'll
need that so I'll go through that so
actually turns out that what's hard to
explain but not so hard but just the
hardest part of these two things is to
explain what a functor is why don't you
understand that a monad is just a
practical thing that enables you to work
with functors so they start there
so a functor is a container well not
that kind of container also not a
dependency injection container also not
a shipping container it's more it's just
a data structure it's a container of
values so we could try to illustrate
that by just saying well it's just sort
of you know some rectangle and you can
imagine that there are some data inside
that
so typically in a language like C sharp
this would be a generic type so this
would be some sort of container of tea
something like that so one thing we know
about it is that it contains values of
the generic type tea and it supports
what we call a structure preserving map
and what that means is that you can
change whatever is inside the container
without actually changing you know the
outside look and feel of the container
if you will and that sounds abstract I
know so let's look at an example now the
the most intuitive way to think about
this is just think about it as a
collection so here's a collection of
numbers what is just what is the
structure preserving map well you can
add one to each of the numbers and now
you have a new collection of numbers and
since it's a generically typed container
and not only do you have to you don't
have to translate numbers to numbers you
can translate numbers to string so you
can translate numbers to boolean values
or whatever you would like so this idea
of this translation being structure
preserving means that it preserves the
structure of the input container
whatever it is and the structure depends
a little bit on what type of container
we have so this is just an example you
know collections are just one example of
this overall abstract concept of a
functor but for collections the
structure is something like the size so
you know the input collection here has
the size of six elements or all the
outputs all also have that same size and
there's an order to a collection and
that means the order of all the outputs
here is determined by the order of the
input collection as well so that's the
structure of typical collections in a
list of T arrays you know any irony
mobile of T stuff like that what's just
one example of a functor now one is
another thing we might learn about
functors is that the output is still the
same type of container so you know a
collection maps to another collection
and that means you can you can keep on
doing this so you can say let's map that
to something else so you can sort of
compose those things together so that's
that's a pretty nice ability to have so
in c-sharp this looks something like
this so well let's create an array of
numbers and then to reform the first
structure for serving map we call this
selects method so most other languages
call that structure preserving map map
or maybe F map but in c-sharp it's
called select for reasons now this is
the first step it just corresponds to
the first step that I showed you on the
diagram and this is just adding one to
each of the numbers and that produces a
new array or new ienumerable at least
and then you can move on and do this you
know another select and that turns all
the the numbers into strings and now you
have yourself an array of strings so you
know this already you know you've if
you've ever done c-sharp programming
you've you've been doing this for more
than 10 years link has been around for a
long time so you'd say well okay so we
if that is an example of a functor and
and it is why would anyone ever ask the
question how do I get the value out of
my functor because it's sort of like why
would you ask something like how do I
get the value out of my collection it's
not a very reasonable question to ask
because we know that there's more than
one value and what's even worse
sometimes there's no value in an array
or in our lists so it doesn't make sense
to ask the question how do I get the
value out of a collection particularly
if that collection is empty so people
don't ask questions in you know just
like that so you'd say well why why do
people ask you know well how do I get
the value out of my monad if you knew
this already but the problem is that
most people actually don't realize that
this is a functor because if you read
the documentation of what a functor but
selector does it doesn't tell you that
it's a functor even though it is so I
don't know why Microsoft chooses to keep
keep the truth from you but I know you
can handle the truth so now I'm telling
you alright so I think the reason why
that question keeps coming up is that
you know you've been using and and
working with link for yes but you don't
realize that you're working with
functors so the first time you actually
gets introduced to the concept of
functors and monads is in a different
context and if you're unlucky maybe that
context is what I call a unit container
so the word unit containers just my
invention but I use that to describe a
set of very specific functors that have
one thing in common and that is that
they contain exactly one value so
guarantee to contain one value and for
those it makes sense to ask that
question so lazy of tea for example
again a time that's been around in the
dotnet library for like 15 years this is
guaranteed to contain a single value of
the type T and that it's always kind of
it contain exactly one value it's just a
lazy computation so it's already
generically typed is it a factor then
well again for reasons that I don't
understand it doesn't come with a select
method but we can add 1 so we can write
as you know an extension method so we'll
say let's write a method called selects
that returns a lacy of T the solved if
the input is a lacy of T and which is
going to need a function that translates
T to t result and the implementation is
basically just a one-liner it's just
that line of code and this preserves
this the structure of what it means by
being a lazy computation and I'll give
you an example here so imagine that you
create a lazy of end and you'll notice
that inside the lazy computation it'll
block the thread for 10 seconds but even
so this code couldn't you know it
immediately completes because it's a
lazy computation so it's actually not
running yet you have a lazy of int so
it's sort of like a promise to calculate
an int at a later time but not right now
so you can take that select method that
we just added that extension method and
you can call it on X to produce a lazy
of string and this still completes
immediately so that means you know
whatever you expect from a lazy
computation is still true not only does
this still complete immediately now if
you now force evaluation and say y dot
value that's gonna block for 10 seconds
and if you do it again it's gonna return
immediately because it remembers the
result from the first time you forced
evaluation and this is just how you
expect lazy of T to behave so the Select
method just preserves your expectations
it just you know stays intuitive if you
will so that's a structure preserving
map in your if it preserves the
invariance of what it means to be a lazy
computation so all that takes is just an
extension method called select and we
can do the same thing for task of T so
the implementation is a little bit
different
it works the same way so you can say
let's create a task of int and again
that completes immediately even though
it starts the task on a background
thread somewhere and that means you can
take your X in your task of Ind and call
select on that to turn it into a task of
string and again that's gonna complete
immediately because select preserves the
structure of what it means to be an
asynchronous computation even and even
more you know if you try to await Y then
it's gonna block until the task is
completed but then again if you try to
do it again that's gonna complete
immediately so again selects doesn't
change your expectations you know the
task of string behaves just like you
would expect a task to behave doesn't
change anything so it's a structure for
serving map so now you've seen a couple
of examples of functors you've seen
collections you've seen Lacey of tea
you've seen tasks of tea those are all
functors because they have structure for
serving maps and in Sharpe we call those
select alright we can actually do more
with this so so far you've seen me use
this syntax but we could also rewrite
all the expressions that you've seen so
far to query syntax and this is the
syntax most people associated with
database queries but this works on you
know if X is any ienumerable of int then
Y is inferred to be any ienumerable of
string but it turns out that now we've
added those select methods this also
works for lazy of T and it also works
for tasks of T so it might be a little
bit surprising that the this language
feature works for your custom types but
the reason why it works is because that
language feature is designed around the
abstraction of a functor and if the
compiler can see that you have created a
functor then this syntax compiles so
they knew what they were doing when they
were creating that sort of syntax even
if you can disagree with the namings
naming conventions they chose so that's
basically a functor it's some sort of
generically typed as a container that
supports the structure preserving map so
now we just need to figure out what a
monad is and I would say you know just
getting your head around that is a very
very abstract
you know sort of fossa concept that a
function it's not an interface that you
implement it's just sort of you know if
you're if your data looks in a
particular way then it's a funk term now
if you can get that you know figuring
out what a monad is is easy because just
that is just solving a practical problem
with functors and basically what I told
you is it's a function you can flatten
so let's just have a look at what does
it mean to flatten a functor we haven't
really seen something that doesn't look
flat already so we'll probably have to
just briefly go through that so and
we'll go back to collections for a
little moment so here's a string it's a
it's a string of food coma bar but it's
just one string and there's an instance
method on string called split and that
enables you to split on a character so
in this case we're going to split on the
comma and the result of that is just a
you know an array of strings foo and bar
so that's fine and you probably knew
this already now what if you have a
collection of comma separated strings
like this foo bar and bass and cukes now
if you want to do a pro structure
preserving map over those two strings
but you also want to split each of those
comma separated strings now what's going
to happen now is split it's going to
produce a race in itself so you now you
get a nested array you can under ray of
a race so that's what I mean by a nested
container sometimes this is what you
want but sometimes you just want you
know the just a flat array instead of
this array of arrays so what you can do
instead is you can call a method called
select many you've probably tried this
already and the reason why it's called
select many is exactly because it
addresses this problem and it says well
you're going to select for each of the
comma separated strings but the
operation that I'm gonna you know
execute inside that lambda expression
split will produce many values so for
each of the input elements I'm gonna
produce many values so I'm gonna select
many and now I've kind of flattened as I
go and then I just have a nice flat on
nested container so this is just an
array of strings instead of up being an
array of array of strings so that's what
I mean by flattening a functor if you
have select many and it's well-behaved
then it's a monad that's basically what
makes it a monad it's just solving that
practical problem that sometimes you
need to remove levels of nesting from a
generically type container that's all it
is
all right so would you ever run into
that situation with other site types of
functors what about tasks well what if
you define a task of index and another
task of into why and then you say well
I'd like to add them together but I'd
like to do it in the functor style so
I'll call select and I'll try to do
something like this now if you do this
this compiles but you'll notice that the
output Z is a task of a task of an IND
now how do you get the int out of that
task by the way well you can actually
await a wait Zed it's not of funny that
you can do that but that actually works
pretty well but it's it's it's a little
odd isn't it so and instead what you can
do is you can add just like you added a
select extension method you can add a
select many extension methods and that
means it's just gonna flatten as it goes
and now Z is just a normal task of in
that you only have to await at once in
order to actually get it get the value
out of it and not only that you know
with the appropriate select many methods
you could also just rewrite everything
in query syntax you know and it would
look like this so it's it's because you
know task of end is a monad that this is
possible to do the compiler understands
monads as well as functors so so that's
another example of a monad you can just
flatten things as you go and then that's
a monad now there are definitely
examples where it makes sense to ask the
question how do I get the value out of
the data container for a lacy of string
you can get the string out of it by
forcing evaluation the same thing goes
for you no task you have to weight them
but you can then get at the string and
this is not only true for c-sharp this
you know you run into the same situation
in in F sharp there's something very
similar called async of string and even
in Haskell you have those unit
containers that are guaranteed to
contain just one value and you can
access that value by run a function on
on the container
not all of them but a lot of them this
is just the simplest one that exists so
if this is your introduction to
functions and monads and your brain is
trying to pattern match on
and you sort of have forgotten that
collections are also functors and monads
maybe you reach that wrong conclusion
that you can always get the value out of
the monad because for these containers
it's true but there's lots of other
Monet's let's not lots of other
containers where that's not true and
people often run into problems with what
I call semi containers so unit
containers were the ones that were
guaranteed to contain exactly one value
now so I just you know name the other
ones here semi containers because
they're not guaranteed to contain one
value they may contain a value but maybe
they don't so on average if you will
they contain half a value semi stupid I
know
anyways and the most famous one in C
sharp is probably novel of T and you
know novel of T already so if you have
you know inaudible the int we we looked
at that already
that's an ID here's a slightly different
example you could make a check on ID and
see if it's not no and if it's not null
you know that it's safe to access ID but
value and then you have this customer
object here that requires a you know a
proper int so that would be some sort of
customer in a identity customer ID and
you can only create a customer if you
have an int that you can pass to the to
the constructor there so you can say
well if that's possible if it's safe to
access ID that value I can create a new
customer and I can return that but
whenever you're returning something you
also have to deal with the case where
there's nothing there so what do you
write in the il's front here and I know
what lots of people do they do this
and it is you know this should not be
allowed according to the Geneva
Convention because it's it's what you're
doing here is you're leaving behind a
mine you know you creating a little
helper method there that says well you
know here's something where you know the
return value is a customer and and then
you keep you know you you give that you
know helper method to me and you say
well just call this method and you will
have a customer and I'll say oh gee I'll
have a customer I'll start you know
calling your method and you know do
things with the customer and everything
compiles and all is fine and then I you
know put my code into production and
everything just explodes so if you
structure your code like this that's
just sort of like creating a minefield
it is really really hard to navigate
code that is structured like this so
please don't but you know it's hard if
you don't know what else to do so the
question is then since I'm talking about
functions and monads can they help you
so let's let's have a look at that so is
is normal of T a functor well it's again
it's not but we can make it a functor by
creating it's an extension method and
called select but there's one catch on
that that is this only compiles if we
add those generic type constraints here
T must be a struct T results must be a
struct and the reason for that is that
novel of T itself is defined it's only
defined for T's where T is a struct so
you can only map between you know value
types but then you know it's a functor
overall value value types but not
overall types in general but you can if
you want write something like this where
you can say well let's start with an AA
level of int and then you know transform
that into an all above a bool and that
works and so that's that's quite useful
so you'd say well okay so there's the
nice thing about you know doing those
you know structure preserving maps with
select is that you don't have to check
for null you don't have to check whether
the values there or not you can just say
well you know well just compose my is
even method with I dot select and you
know all H cases are actually being
taken care of here so that's really nice
can can I do something like this with my
ID you know I had
I had to create that customer we've
before it'd be really nice if we could
do something like this and and that
would be safe so I could say ID dot
select and then say you know if ID is a
value there's an integer inside of it
and then that I in the lambda expression
would be the integer and then I could
create a new customer that really really
nice yeah but doesn't compile sorry and
the reason for that is that you know
customer is a reference type and we had
that type constraint saying t can only
be a value type so sorry
that's c-sharp 8th made may do something
about c-sharp 8th will do lots of things
so let's just pretend that she saw it's
not happened yet because it hasn't and
we don't really know exactly how it's
going to work out anyway so we'll just
pretend that what we can do though is
that we can say well okay so it'd be
nice if nah level of T just lifted that
constraint and until c-sharp
Eights and then we can't really make
that happen magically but we can just
make our own functor so we'll make our
own functor and we'll call it something
and we'll have to come up with a good
name and we'll just think about calling
it maybe of T because that's what
everyone else calls it so I didn't come
up with that idea and there's lots of
ways you can implement this but here I'm
just using a flag and a value and then
there's two constructor overload
there's one constructor that doesn't
take any arguments and it just sets that
has item flag to false and there's
another constructor overloading an item
of the type T as input and you know
saves it in a class field and sets the
flag to true so these are now enables
you to to the to model you know a
generically type container that may or
may not contain a value so it's already
generically typed is it a functor well
not surprisingly it is we just have to
implement the Select method so it
doesn't have to be an extension method
this is an instance method on maybe of T
and the output of that should be a may
be of T result so how do we implement
this that's pretty straightforward just
ask you know is has item true or false
if it's true we know that item is
available we know that item is of the
type T the selector that function that
is being passed in
is a function that can take a value of
the type T and turn it into a value of
type T result and we have a value of
type T that's items that we call
selector with item that produces a value
of T result and then we just package
that in a populated maybe of T result do
that works what do we do in the other
case do we throw an exception now we
don't have to we just return an empty
maybe maybe of T result that doesn't
contain anything and that's all good so
again this is a structure preserving map
because we are taking populated maybes
and translating them to other populated
maybes and we're taking empty maybes and
translating them to other empty maybes
so we preserve the structure of whatever
the original maybe was we're not
changing things around and we can do the
same thing with the Select mini so with
this flattening operation and it just
looks a little bit different but you
know the concept is the same so I'm just
gonna skip over this briefly now what
you can do with the maybe of T is that
you can create some nice composable
helper functions so you could write
something like try pass IND
and then you'd say well that's got a
return or maybe event but why do we need
this we already have you know interests
a try pass in the base class library so
why is this necessary and it's but this
is composable you know because what's
often the problem when you use you know
in to try pass is that you have to check
whether it returns true or false and you
normally don't have a problem when the
return value is true because then you
have yet the integer that you were
looking for and all is good and in this
case we just put that into a maybe event
but often then again you run into this
problem what do I do in the else branch
if I didn't you know I'd look for an
integer and I didn't find one so what do
I do and this is again where you know in
many other cases people would throw
exceptions but no no just return an
empty one and that's that's gonna solve
your problem now this is safe and you
can do the same thing with with passing
dates and it's exactly the same template
here so if you imagine that you have to
write a little application that says you
know enables you to rent a car what you
can do is you could say well the first
thing you want to ask you about is you
know you have a little method there
called collect state and when you call
that it's gonna ask
user okay please input the date on which
you want to start your rental and then
the user types in a date and that's a
string and then you pass the string to
try past date and now you have a maybe
at a time and then you ask the user okay
so for how many days would you like to
rent the car and the user types in the
answer and that's an a string and then
you pass that into a maybe event and
then you ask some more questions and
once you have asked all the questions
you'd like to ask you can start to you
know compile all or compose all of those
values into a maybe of contract so you
can use query syntax and you say from D
and MD so D is now because of the way
query syntax works D is just a date/time
value and you can say from I in MI and
is just an IND and then finally you can
say select contract and then you could
just pass in all those various different
primitive values there so what you end
up with is a maybe of contract that may
or may not actually contain a contract
but it's safe no exceptions will be
thrown here it's either gonna be there
or it's not gonna be there but it's just
quite explicit that you have to deal
with both cases so so far so good now
this is fine but then this is where
people start to run into problems
because they say well okay contract is a
class and it contains some methods that
I'd like to call because there's for
example a calculate price method and I
need to call the calculate price method
because I want to show a quote to the
user and say this is what that rental is
going to cost you so people start doing
stuff like this where they say let's
declare a decimal called qq4 quote and
then we test whether the item is there
and if it's there we'll try to you know
actually you know get at the item inside
and call calculate price on that and
again yeah that doesn't compile and I
very deliberately designed the API for
maybe so that this doesn't compile I hit
those you know it has item and item as
private fields because you're not
supposed to do this because it's brittle
you know again what's gonna happen if
that boolean expression is false it's
gonna it's not gonna leave Q as 0
do you want to run the risk of
accidentally ending up showing a quote
to a user with a price of zero this is
what error handling and you know
complicated branching will often lead to
you know 20 years ago I was doing
e-commerce websites and there was
actually a bug on this site that did
exactly that you know because we would
we did something wrong and instead of
actually you know pulling prices out of
the database or whatever
everything was just you know initialized
and what's the default value of an
integer well that's 0 so everything was
just free on the what web shop no it's
not a good problem to have
so yeah not not a good way to structure
your code what should we do instead
let's let's try it again we know that
maybe of T is a functor so that means we
it's a pause a structure preserving map
so what if instead we just did something
like this where we say let's just it
call select on MC and that means inside
of that we'll pass a lambda expression
that calls see to calculate price and
the output of that of that is a maybe of
decimal and this is a structure
preserving map you know if maybe if
contract was populated then the may be
of decimals you're also gonna be
populated if it was empty then the
result is gonna be empty as well but
it's safe you don't need to do it then
any if else checking it doesn't throw
exceptions this is always safe to do so
um it's basically answers the question
you know how do I get the value out of
my monad well you don't you inject the
desired behavior into the monad and
that's basically what we did you know I
just took that calculate price and said
it's gonna happen inside the maybe
container I'm not taking it out of maybe
I'm just putting the behavior inside the
container and just you know transforming
the the context as I go along if you
will so this is safe and that's the way
you're supposed to work with monads and
I know what you're going to say now I
always say well yeah but you know
ultimately I need to produce a result
and I need to put you know I can't you
know display a maybe of decimal on the
screen I need to you know give the user
price yeah but again you know if you
don't have a price you don't want to
display zero then you want to display an
error message or something like that and
that's
that's another thing you don't want to
get the value out you need to figure out
how to arrive at a final result it's not
quite the same problem so let's go back
to the collections again and see what
how do we solve the problem here now
sometimes you can just say well okay I
have a collection of numbers let's just
put all the numbers back you know to on
the screen because that's what the user
wants but often it's not but then the
next question is if if you just want to
produce one result after out of an array
like this is there a you know ubiquitous
single result that you should always
produce from an array like this no it
depends on what you're trying to do
maybe you want the sum and you can call
you know a specific method on that that
calculates the sum and that's that
number then maybe you want the average
and I believe there's also a specific
method that you need that calculates the
average but maybe you want to do
something where there's no you know
built-in method for it maybe you want to
multiply all the numbers together so in
order to address all the situations
where there's no specialized method for
it there's something called aggregate
and I'm using an overload here that
takes a seed so I set the seat to one
and the reason why I do that is it's not
really necessary here but if the input
array is empty aggregate can't work
unless it knows where to start so if the
input was empty it would just return the
seed the seat and that would be one
otherwise that lambda expression to the
to the right there is gonna run pairwise
for each of the elements starting with
the seed in the first element and and in
this case I'm just gonna multiply all
the values together and the result here
is not very interesting because it's
zero because one of the numbers inside
of that array is zero so not so
interesting but the concept of being
able to you know produce a single value
a single aggregate with the lambda
expression and maybe a little seed we
can take that concept and also apply
that concept to maybe and we can make it
annexed in an instance method and I'm
gonna call it match so this is an
instance method on maybe of T that
returns a T result so I'm keeping things
flexible here I'm not saying that we
should return you know
even though this is a maybe of tea I'm
not saying we should return a tea we can
you know transform as we go and that
turns that keeps things flexible so
basically it's just you know using the
ternary operator it's just a one-liner
if has item if that flag is true we know
that item is available but item is of
the type T we need to transform it into
T result because that's the return value
that we need and we have a function
called just and don't worry about why
it's called that is that's just the name
that it's called that's a function from
T to T results so we can just call that
on item and if has item is false if that
flag is false we don't have anything but
then we have that fallback you know
nothing value of the type T we solve
them we can return that that's sort of
like the seed from the aggregate
function there and so this enables us to
always aggregate or collapse you know a
maybe value into a single value so now
we can return to the third part of the
talk how do I combine the impotency
injection with a sink and a weight
without leaky abstractions so we sort of
left off by saying well you know when
you do a sink it needs to be a sink all
the way and then I said well but wait
there is an alternative so let's see
what that is so what I'm going to do now
isn't gonna move the impure operations
to the boundary of the system and I'm
gonna explain what that means but
basically the idea is that you have some
interactions with the real world and
they tend to be what we call impure and
just gonna move those to the boundary of
the system and in object-oriented
programming terminology we would just
say that that supports an adaptive
application architecture so this is
something that's been a been around for
decades and it's a well-known
well-respected object oriented
architecture so we should be in good
hands here now what's an impure
operation well it's basically just
something that interacts with an
environment and we have two examples
here so I'm I'm just going to explain
what impure is but you know by way of
example so when you call read
reservations you are querying a database
so that's probably what you're doing and
that is basically a non-deterministic
operation because you can query a
database with you know let's say I want
the I want all the reservations for this
Sunday and then you query the database
you get some reservations
and then ten minutes later you say I
want all the reservations for this
Sunday so the same input argument but
now you get you know a new result back
because the state of the database
changed and we don't consider the state
of the database to be part of the
function itself so you know just viewed
from the perspective of the code that
basically looked random even even though
it's not random it is determined by the
state of the database we still consider
that to be non-deterministic so it's
it's things that we'd like to happen you
know at the boundary of the system and
not inside the domain logic now another
problem here is repository create this
is problematic for a different reason
because it creates a side effect it
creates a record in the database it
changes the state of the database so
everything that has a side effects it's
also sometimes in something that well we
want this to happen but we just won't
don't want to have it to happen deep
within our business logic because it
makes it difficult to write the
appropriate business logic so we'll we
want to move both of those things to the
boundary of the system so let's start
with the first one this is the easiest
one to do will them look at repository
reservations and we'll notice that this
method is always being invoked
unconditionally so you could say well
why should this try/except method even
have this responsibility to call
repositories read reservations
isn't that just making things more
complicated than they have to be why why
shouldn't we just say well if you want
you know try except to do its work you
should tell it how many reservations
that are already in the system and we
can do that by just saying well instead
of calling the method we just make that
a requirement for calling the the method
for calling the try/except method and
that we do that by saying let's promote
this to a method document this is a
fairly easy change but well sometimes
things have to get worse before they get
better this is not you know this leaves
us a little bit of a bad place because
we need to go and change the IMH of the
interface in order to make everything
compile and then you'd probably say well
okay so you made a specific
implementation change in the try/except
method and now you have to change the
interface as well at that point you'd
probably say well okay
that's if that's a leak you know this is
a leaky abstraction if I ever saw one
that's much worse than the other things
that I've talked about so um how can you
defend that and I say well you know if I
had to stop here I don't think that I
could defend it but this is just the
first in a series of refactorings that
I'm going to do and when I'm done with
all the refactorings things are gonna be
good so you're just gonna have to trust
me for now that this will all end well
even though it doesn't look so good
right now
so going back to the post method on the
controller we we have already injected
the I'm A to D dependency what we can do
now is we can just say this also take a
dependency on the repository because if
we do that we can just call read
reservations here instead of inside the
mate the maitre d to try accept method
and then we can pass those reservations
to the try accept method and then all
the rest of the code is just the same as
before so this is a fairly easy change
to make I'm just literally just moving a
method call to another place in the code
and then I'm done with that so that that
wasn't too hard the other change here is
a little bit harder because the problem
here is that repository to create is not
getting executed unconditionally there's
a branch a little bit further off that
returns null and when that happens you
know repository create never gets cold
so how do we how do we deal with that
problem well if we want to move
repository create to the cloning site we
sort of have to figure out a way to
communicate the decision that we made so
that the caller can then act upon that
decision so one way we could do that we
could say well we already know how to
communicate our decision to the caller
because we were returning that known
honorable int and we talked about how
you know a proper integer means you have
a reservation ID and that means the X
you know the reservation was accepted
and null meant that it wasn't so we
could do something like that but the
problem is that the end potentially if
we have an integer that comes from
calling repository create because that's
the return value from calling repository
create so if I move repository create to
the
all side i no longer have an integer to
return so instead of having an integer
to return i need something else than an
integer I'd like to return you know
something like no level of reservation
instead but now I'm running into this
type constraint unknowable of T that T
must be a struct so if instead of using
novel of T I'd use maybe of T I can lift
that constraint I can get rid of that
so the first refactoring I'd like to do
is to change my novel of int to
inaudible of to a maybe event because
that's going to set me up for making
another refactoring afterwards so if you
just keep your eye on the top line of
code there where it says nullable int
I'm just going to change that to a maybe
event and the changes to the code itself
are fairly minimal
I'm just instead of returning null I'm
returning a maybe of in that is empty
and instead of returning these integers
directly I'm gonna package that integer
that comes from repository key trade I'm
just gonna package that in a populated
maybe so again I'm have to change the
OMH of the interface but apart from that
but post method I'm still gonna call
Maitre D' to try except what I have now
though is a maybe event and you saw
before that you can't do this check
where you say is it populated or not and
then sort of do an if-else bronze here
by design you're not allowed to do that
but what you can do is you can say let's
call the match method and if you use
argument named arguments you can say
well the first argument needs to be the
nothing case and that's in that case we
kind of return internal server error in
the just case we'll need to supply a
little function that can turn an integer
into an action results so I'm just going
to write a little lambda expression that
receives the integer ID and just you
know returns okay of ID so ID is now
guaranteed to be an integer it is not
you know something that could be not
there it is guaranteed to be there so
it's safe to just do that and you don't
have to do all sorts of Defense encoding
around this because that's part of how
functors and monads work right
okay so now we're in the position where
we can finally move repository create to
the boundary of the system so I'm
basically just going to take it away but
if I do that I don't have an int to
return so what I'm going to do instead
is I'm gonna return a maybe of
reservation so either an empty one or
one that that is just the reservation
that I just accepted and again I have to
change the maitre d interface but that's
okay it's gonna be okay and if I do that
I now have a maybe of reservation and
remember that the the contract that I
have with my HTTP client is that in the
case where I returned 200 okay I should
return an integer which is the
reservation ID and right now I don't
have an integer how do i turn my maybe a
reservation into a maybe of int I call
the Select method so I'll just do that
and I say well I'm just gonna you know
take whatever reservation is inside if
there is one and I'm gonna call
repository create and repository create
returns an int so now I have a maybe
event but not quite I actually have a
maybe of a task of an int because this
is asynchronous but it's okay
you know task is a monad maybe as a
monad and that combination also turns
out to be a monad so all is good still
the match method looks a little bit
awkward right now we'll fix it up and
make it prettier later on but it's
because we have this combination of
maybe and tasks it looks a little bit
odd with the task from resolves and
stuff like that but don't worry about
that that's got to be pretty as well but
we have a compiler warning now if we go
back to try except it says this async
method lacks await operators and yeah it
does it says async but there's no weight
because I deliberately try to get rid of
those and I actually succeeded now so
yes a you know bang just away with that
you know no reason to make this
asynchronous this was what bothered me
originally and now I've solved my
problem Maitre D' now looks like this it
still looks leaky will still solve that
problem but the only change we have to
make to the post method is that Maitre
D' two tracks have used to be
asynchronous it's not anymore so we'll
just remove the wait keyword
I'll just do it one more time if you
weren't paying attention you know it
says I wait there now it doesn't say
you're wait that's the only change cool
one more thing we can do it just gets it
just gets better and better once you
sort of crack the not just you you guess
you could just keep improving these
things because now we go back to the
maitre d object here again and we say
well gee that you know repository
dependency it's not being used a weight
with that you know that just simplifies
things as well so what we have now is
pretty much close to what we could call
a pure function well it's in quotes
because there is saying this is state
mutation happening on the penultimate
line there and says it's except it's
it's that's true so we could address
that concern if we were concerned with
that but the major point here is that
this is now entirely deterministic you
know the way that this code is going to
execute only depends on the input
arguments and nothing else there are no
other dependencies involved that will in
you know influence how this code
executes and them easy completely
deterministic we can control exactly
what happens just by making sure that it
gets the appropriate input values so if
we go back and look at the post method
we'd say well why do we have that I
Maitre D' dependency there and some of
you may say well it's it's really there
because we need to be able to unit test
the controller and then you know with
unit testing we can create a test double
you know a mock or stop and then we can
control how Maitre D' depends but then I
say well yeah but you know with the
maitre d the way that I've implemented
that now you can control how it behaves
you just make have to make sure that it
receives the appropriate input values so
this is just as deterministic as hiding
it behind a mock or stop so if you make
that change you've removed the IMHO d
dependency and if you do this
consistently you don't lead the
interface anymore so you can just get
rid of it so that's why you know in the
end it doesn't matter because that
that's now gone I'm running out of time
so I'm just going to wrap up here this
still looks a little bit odd but we can
make it prettier
if you're interested in exactly how you
get from that you know previous example
to this I have a blog post and a lot of
all the source code is on github so you
can sort of read through this but you'll
notice that we start out by calling
repository to read reservations and then
we go select select many and stuff like
that
so since we can call select many less
there must be a monad somewhere and
which one is that well it's the task of
team monad or the async monad if you
will so you'll notice that everything
that needs to be asynchronous is still
asynchronous you know read reservations
on the top line or the first line there
that's an asynchronous operation and I
just continued that asynchronous
operation by going select on the tasks
of T and then you know I also had a
little bit further down I have you know
repository create this is also an e
synchronous method and it needs to be
asynchronous and it is so that's all
fine and the post way that itself is
asynchronous because it returns a task
of async result of action result so
everything that needs to be asynchronous
is asynchronous but the domain model I
just injected that into the asynchronous
context but it's actually synchronous
but it's just sitting there in the
asynchronous context and doesn't know
that it's now being part of an
asynchronous workflow it's just doing
whatever it's designed to do so how do
we combine asing in a weight without
leaky abstractions well you inject the
desired behavior into the async monad or
the task of T monad and this is just a
specialization of the answer that we
already arrive that with monads you just
inject the desired behavior into the
monad so we should have known this
already so behavior injection not
dependency injection so if you want to
know more I have articles that run you
through all of the code that I've shown
you here and there's a link to github as
well with all the code there and right
now if you're concerned about the that I
remove that I'm a 2d interface and say
well but the implementation is
deterministic I'm currently in the
process of publishing articles that talk
about that problem as well so
I've written them but they're not all
published yet so if you follow me on
Twitter or if you subscribe to the blog
then you'll get notified when those are
available as well and with that I'm I'm
a little bit over time and I apologize
for that so I'm not gonna take any
questions but I'm gonna hang around in
the conference and I'll be happy to talk
to you if you have questions for me but
those of you who just want to get out
you're welcome to just run away in right
now but thank you for coming
[Applause]
Hey
[Music]